(Chuckles)
(Clapping)
♪♪
(Wall rolling)
(Struggles)
-Ahh!
Good luck to us both.
(Phone vibrates)
(Gasps)
-Oh!
(Door opens)
(Door closes)
♪♪
Sam:
I've blamed bad luck for
everything that's gone wrong in my life.
♪♪
You sure have bad luck, Sam
Greenfield.
Ugh!
Sam:
Take that, universe!
Whoa!
-(Shelf crashes down)
Marvin:
Ow!
Sam:
Until
♪♪
Sam:
I found an actual lucky penny!
♪♪
Ah!
(Whack)
Sam:
Something that could finally
turn my life around.
♪♪
Sam:
Yes! Yes! Yes! Yes!
And what did I do?
(Gasps)
Sam:
I flushed it down the toilet.
(Toilet flushes)
You flushed my penny down the
toilet?
(Gasps)
You just...talked.
Wait!
I just need another penny!
Whoa!
♪♪
Sam:
Whoa!
♪♪
Always with the obnoxiously long
password!
♪♪
Sam:
Ah!
♪♪
Bob:
Screams!
Humans cannot be here!
-Where's here?
Bob:
The land of luck.
I'll leave as soon as you give
me another lucky penny.
Bob:
You best start blendin' in.
Hello.
-Ah!
Mighty leprechaun fraulein!
Well done, nature!
Gerry:
This is where good luck is born.
Sam:
A dragon?
Gerry:
She's the only creature that can
sniff out bad luck.
There's bad luck here, too?
Good luck on top,
Gerry:
bad luck on the bottom.
♪♪
The tiniest amount of bad luck
Dragon:
can shut down our entire
operation.
(Thud)
Leprechaun:
Mhmm.
Just how unlucky are you?
(Step breaks)
-Ahh!
Ow!
Oh no!
Ah!
(Bell dings)
(Bell thud)
Ugh!
Super, duper unlucky.
You cause a disaster!
Sam:
-Ow!
Bob:  -Ugh!
Dragon:
The good luck connection has
been severed.
♪♪
Sam:
I doomed you and everyone else
to a life of bad luck.
Sam;
We need to fix this.
Ahh!
Bad luck ogre:
What are you doing here?
(Smack)
-Ow!
Ahh!
-No!
Ow!
♪♪
Good luck to us both.
What about Jeff?
(Speaking German)
I have no words.